it really happened by accident Breanna
is relatable AF and that is no accident
she's proved it once again in this
makeup free moment
sky's the limit no rules I could do
whatever I want
we shared her first selfie of the decade
to Instagram rocking a laid-back look in
a black zipped hoodie with her braided
hair pulled up instead of a scandalous
pic freeing the nipple the makeup mogul
opted to free the pimple it's always
very nerve-wracking it's not very
comfortable come on Ari
there's nothing uncomfortable about
relatability one of her followers even
joked let me pop your pimple Rihanna
clap back in the best way writing let
her have her shine please oh those
things are the ingredients that make me
let's be honest Rihanna's Navy isn't
concerned about a tiny blemish on the
Barbadian beauty's face they're focused
on when her ninth studio album will drop
y'all gonna have to wait maybe I'm so
sorry
et spoke with the 31 year old singer in
October here's what she teased I hear
you'd registered private loving best no
that's not that's not true okay it's not
gonna be the title not give me something
about the album or a pending I could get
out a Dada and a dog reggae thank you
yes you already knew that though we
besties you should know I'm trying to
get you to expand mama you know what I
did maybe a little bit
when I have more information you will be
the first to know
[Music]